i forgot to bring a lemon so i'm just
going to hold this and you guys can cg
11 in later you have the budget for that
right
here make the lemon move around oh god
your budget is going up every second
this could be the most expensive
essential items ever
[Music]
hey i'm kamel nanjiani and i'm here with
gq to talk about my 10 essentials
first one it's not that exciting it's a
computer i should have cleaned it for
this wow this is filthy
and i have a little sticker on here
because my wife and i have the same
computer and so we have a little sticker
so we know who's is who the sticker i
used to have on the other one was an
ampersand that to me signified like
keep going and what else and
then i found it was too much pressure so
i was like no i'm gonna go the other way
have less pressure when i'm doing work
and so i took that off to me it
signifies like somebody like like a
neutral expression like when i start my
computer i don't want to be in any
specific place let's see where it goes
[Music]
i always travel with a video game
console which is very embarrassing
because i don't check stuff in so when
when people are like putting their
laptops
in the bins i'm pulling out my xbox
because you have to pull that out it's a
little embarrassing right now i'm
replaying mass effect which is a story
about
people are going to get bored
space
nice can i swear
it's a bunch of space
you're in a spaceship fighting space
i don't want anything set in the present
i'm already in the present i'm trying to
get away from here so i've used to play
online a lot and i was
i was really good almost too good uh i
got to the point where i forget which
halo it was but it was one of the halos
i was ranked like
my level was 48 which to you it means
nothing but trust me it's very high and
i was like
okay
i shouldn't have
wireless controllers anymore because if
they're wired you can only throw them so
far
all right
now i'll just talk about an app i have
on my phone it is called calm
and it's just a meditation app
and i use it every day i uh just plug in
my headphones and i just do 10 minutes
with
tamara levitt i don't know who she is
but i hear her voice every day for 10
minutes i have no idea what she looks
like i think i'd be very starstruck if i
ever met tamara levitt and on the days i
don't do it
i really feel it i haven't done it today
and i'm really like oh man
all right here we go
let's see
close your eyes
feel the weight of gravity pulling you
down
relax your forehead
relax your eyes
let your lips curl into a
small smile
and whenever you're ready
you're on the beach
there are no no piranhas on this beach
there's no sharks
no murders are occurring on this beach
it's one of the good beaches nobody's
ever
nobody's ever died on this beach i
shouldn't focus on the bad stuff that
isn't happening i should focus on the
good stuff that is happening what do you
think
it's gonna be good right in tomorrow's
meditation you're gonna be riding a
shark
here's another thing i'll talk about
[Music]
if you change your socks in the middle
of the day it changes your whole day i'm
always telling my friends that carry a
pair of socks with you and halfway
through the day just put on a new pair
of socks
you're like a whole new person i've been
doing this for like 15 years or so and
uh i always have an extra pair of socks
on me i don't have particularly sweaty
feet that's not what it is i don't want
people to watch this video and be like
oh i don't need this because camel's got
sweaty smelly feet i don't have sweaty
feet and honestly my feet don't smell i
think it's like just uh whenever you
think of it whenever you feel like you
need like a little jewel to your day you
know i'm realizing how
depressing it is
that when i want
real excitement to show up in my day i
put on a new fresh pair of socks
ah i should get out more i should try
some drugs i've heard those are fun
[Music]
this is not that exciting it's just a
notebook
you know everyone has them i have like
all sorts of stuff in it it's got my
initials on it i don't know somebody
gave them to me i don't always have my
initials on stuff but i have like lists
of movies i want to see or i have seen i
have
recipes for stuff i've tried um i have
notes on like basically anything so i
always have a notebook on me because
sometimes it feels better for me to
write
on something that's
not a computer pair with that this is a
different thing
i'm very particular about my pens now
this is not fancy but
i i write with fountain pens because
what happens is the tip the way you
write it sort of adapts to the way you
write and then it becomes your pen it's
like it's sort of thinking
what you're thinking if i used somebody
else's fountain pen i wouldn't be able
to write with it because it doesn't like
the pressure you apply the way you hold
it all that stuff
doesn't doesn't work so a fountain pen
always have a fountain pen on me oh my
god i could write for hours on this
if only had something to say that's the
best i could do i wrote fountain pen
with a fountain pen i need to change my
socks okay so this is something that
i've recently discovered
these are called oblasts
and it's a
sort of a sweet wafer it can be spanish
or a lot of latin american countries
have it
uh
mexico and it's i'm gonna open it what i
like about it is that it
it takes a long time to eat
and it makes a real mess
like the texture
and there's barely any flavor like this
says chocolate but it's like
it tastes like the memory of chocolate
i've never not eaten a whole one in a
sitting before
if i'd started earlier i would have done
the whole thing you can put jam on them
i don't because i don't want flavor i
just want texture if you could like bite
air that's what this is like
my wife and i call them dusty rounds
because they're round and they just are
very dusty as you can see
i might eat these for the rest of the
shoot
[Music]
i have all these things that i do in the
morning that have become part of ritual
i guess and it's one of them is i have
emergency every day just put it in water
and drink it
it's to the point where just drinking
water is really boring for me i actually
like the raspberry flavor the best but
this is the one that my wife prefers so
we have a bunch of orange right now and
what i have with it is
um
a lemon
i put hot water and i put lemon in it
here's the cup
hot see you can see by all the smoke
that's coming out of it
big fan of coffee
so i always have this on me this is
instant coffee now i i am a coffee snob
and i know a lot of coffee people really
look down on instant coffee but
i grew up drinking instant coffee nest
cafe i was the only one who drank coffee
in my family nobody else drank coffee my
family drank tea and i drank coffee and
i've been drinking coffee since i was
eight years old many many cups of coffee
and my parents had no idea what was in
it and if i think back on my childhood i
remember feeling very high energy
i would stay up all night on weekends
drinking coffee it was a great feeling
anyway so i still like instant coffee i
think nescafe instant coffee still
tastes good to me and then this is like
verve which is like a good fancy coffee
roaster this is their version of instant
coffee and i think it's pretty good yeah
always have coffee on me of course
a mask
[Music]
always have a mask on me and this should
date how long
i've had this mask for remember there
was an election so this was for that
it's gonna be so weird when we find
these things like
10 years from now in our room and be
like oh yeah remember that when we all
wore masks all the time god i hope
in 10 years would like remember when we
used to have to wear masks
uh is this supposed to be devastatingly
depressing or like a fun watch well
thank you so much for listening to my
essentials these are all the things that
i truly cannot live without thanks for
watching and remember go see eternals in
theaters november 5th
it's really good
i haven't seen it yet but
i'm sure it's very good